Peggy's 16  this charming dr. Reid is he new yeah he  arrived a few nights ago was a war  surgeon hired still got bloodstains on  Dresden Hales he's alright that one saw  in me I'll even give me something for  the pain  lovely eyes they had a phone grab ray  enough those hands call this ace there  we're dedicated to his work is always  takes the night shift requested it even  flew in the air  a killer roaming the streets what good  is dedication against that same one of  the corpses myself  Pilar Stefan a yoc was and dr. Reid he's  as white as fresh Lenin himself  oh I've put some color back in them  sheets given out the chance why am I  in a well-known position choose to work  it's rare Lady Luck smiles down on a sea  I just don't know that's not a question  reasons why but some things that place  is too high  and there's always a price  [Music]  you  [Music]